oh
it scrambled down the tree and that type
of speed is real they can run up to 25
miles an hour hey y'all I'm Dr Ray
wingrant I'm a wildlife ecologist and
I've been studying bears for 13 years
today we're going to be looking at bear
attacks and movies and on TV and judging
how real they are
laughs
so already in this clip I see the very
like cinematic Trope of a giant brown
bear standing up on its hind legs and
like roaring at a person honestly in
real life bears are very quiet they
really don't do a lot of growling they
don't do a lot of roaring but if there's
a territory dispute to Big male Alpha
Bears might actually stand up on their
hind legs and Roar at each other and
fight but if there's a big bear and a
small person that bear isn't usually
going to go through all that trouble
we saw that big swipe of the ground
that's something that brown bears and
black bears do in fact I have
experienced a bear do a bluff charge on
me and it is frightening and terrifying
but really they're just trying to freak
you out so that you back up and walk
away and they don't actually have to
attack you
yeah
this is great for TV but it's not
biologically accurate this bear even
though it looks like it could be a
thousand pounds it could scale that wall
no problem those claws could dig into
the wood and it could climb up all the
way and then terrorize all those people
that are watching I'd give it a 7 out of
ten I really wish the bear had climbed
up at the end
let me make it clear that is what you
don't do even if it looks like you might
be attacked by a bear you never run it's
because humans cannot outrun Bears when
humans run it signals to the Predator
that you're prey like that's what a
little deer would do or a little rabbit
would do but when we stand still that's
so different than what prayer would do
that they get the message
no way bears as big and Burly as they
are can also like get into teeny tiny
small spaces I mean I've seen bears like
squeeze themselves into anything they
want so again if it wanted to hurt him
it would
this is interesting so we see that they
made a ring of fire and that's their
tactic of protecting themselves first no
one should ever do this in the
wilderness okay it will start a forest
fire but two there really is something
to this and that's that most wild
animals are afraid of fire that's just
something that they have an experience
right they can't make fire themselves so
as much as I don't want anyone to ever
use this tactic I believe it would be
effective to keep you safe how are we
going to lure him
blood did you see him blood that's not
gonna work okay so like bears are driven
by hunger blood does not necessarily
signal this as something to eat right a
bear wants to smell something delicious
it wants to smell honey it wants to
smell rotting meat I think they're
getting this from the shark thing like
sharks are drawn to blood it's not the
same with bears
so this is actually something that we
use in real life if we want to lure a
bear to something maybe we set up a
little trail cam and we want to get
information on the individual bear we'll
put out what we call a scent Rag and so
it looks just like that like a little
piece of cloth and we'll put some kind
of scent on it we could literally use
like vanilla extract they'll come right
to that rad to see what it is right
right
is it realistic that that bear might
come looking for you again because you
are still in its territory and haven't
left yes however is it realistic that a
bear is going to attack over and over
when there's two or more people no so
bear attacks happen usually when there's
just one person by themselves if you
have two or more it rarely happens which
is another way that people can be safe
when they recreate in nature it did look
real but like the probability of
something like this actually taking
place like I'm gonna give this a 5 out
of 10.
the first shot we see of the bear is of
its claws right those are real claws
they did a great job modeling that it
looks like a real animal and then the
other thing we see is the bear like
sniffing right Fair sense of smell is so
precise and can go across such a long
distance that they're not going to be
sniffing around for a person when
they're literally like two feet from
them Bears can't climb trees of course
they can this little kid just said we're
safe because Bears can't climb trees
right already I'm like oh no like
they're doomed bears are the best tree
climbers
wow Henry move go higher
he's kicking downward with his leg
if you ever find yourself like above a
bear on a tree you should do that but
climbing higher no no no there's a
phrase out there when it comes to bear
attacks if it's black fight back if it's
brown lay down and it's important to
note that this is for bear attacks this
is not for Bear encounters even if a
bear is near you even if it's
approaching you rapidly that's still not
an attack until it's actually like
physically touching you that is a really
important difference because if a bear
is not attacking you that's when you
back away slowly you make yourself look
big if it is attacking you the kid did
it right but the whole time also try to
get out of there
oh
oh it's scrambled down the tree and that
type of speed is real so the bear like
first slowly went up to get the boy of
course I can do that but the way it
practically leapt onto the second tree
and scaled it in a second that's really
when a bear wants something I mean they
can run up to 25 miles an hour also it
should be said
that like Bears don't do drugs it is
totally like hypothetical what a bear
would do if it was like on tons and tons
of cocaine
but this movie is Loosely based off of a
true story but there was a bear in the
80s I believe it was 1985 that was found
dead after ingesting a big amount of
cocaine that was dropped from an
airplane but in general overdoses can
kill animals just like they can kill
people and that's what happened to the
real cocaine bear
hahaha
the only thing that I saw in this Cliff
that wasn't so accurate is that they're
really not that interested in attacking
people right especially black bears
black bears are the least predatory of
all the bear species they mostly have a
vegetarian diet they love their fruit
they love their nuts another thing
people should know is that bears do not
eat people sometimes it's happened like
really really rarely but they do not
prey on humans if a bear is attacking
someone it's really because they
perceive that person as a threat I would
give it like a six out of ten I can't
imagine a bear ever leaving one person
to go attack another person for drugs
thank you
oh oh that's real right behind him comes
what's gotta be Mama Bear the female
bear raises her Cubs and she dedicates
her life to keeping them safe this guy
was technically just standing there but
because he was between the bear and her
cub she sees that as a threat and she
ran right through him so we often tell
people who are like recreating in the
wilderness do not physically come
between a female bear and her cub even
if you notice a bear cub on its own and
you do not see the mama get away from
there immediately you are in danger okay
they lose their mind and they just
attack
so it's actually really really accurate
the way that they showed the attack the
way that the bear uses her teeth the
most like she does a little bit of like
paw stuff she uses those parts of her
the most because they're the most
effective and again she's not trying to
like get a bite to eat right like if she
wanted to eat him she would use her
claws to tear him apart but instead she
just wants to have those fatal bites to
keep her Cubs safe but the biggest myth
that the media shows about bears is that
they're always on the attack in some of
the national parks that have Bears take
Yellowstone National Park your chances
of a bear attack are something like one
in two million so truly bears are
peaceful they're docile and with that
said don't bother them don't frustrate
them and don't trigger them because if
you do you might be in trouble
[Music]
like at this exact spot I wish the
character knew to play dead because this
is a brown bear sometimes called grizzly
bears and with that species it's really
important to play dead because he just
played dead right there it's more likely
that she would like nudge him a little
bit more just to make sure and then walk
away but he's like still making a little
bit of noise and it's telling her like
nope he's still alive he could still be
a threat
this is giving me anxiety
he shot her and then she just attacked
more because she's like see I was right
interest tried to hurt me I'm just gonna
like kill it and rip it to pieces now so
I can understand having a weapon and
wanting to like kill it and fight back
for your life but again you're safer
playing dead until he can no longer hear
or see the bear or her cub honestly I'd
give this one a 10 out of 10. it's
believe it or not a CGI bear but they
really got it right
how did you get up there I don't know of
course like pandas don't really do the
splits but they are flexible all the
little YouTube videos you see of like
pandas in captivity rolling around and
being cute they really do have very
flexible bodies although they're chubby
and fat I now see that the way to get
through to you is with this oh great
realistic that they would want to eat a
lot of food but would they eat delicious
Chinese pork buns I don't think so
however a lot of people don't realize
that pandas although they're vegetarians
and some might think they're herbivores
they're actually still carnivores pandas
have the gut microbiome to digest meat
meaning they have the bacterial
community in their bodies to break down
meat and synthesize it for energy so
that means that it's possible that
ancient pandas were carnivores and ate
meat all the time and probably if they
wanted to they still could
so you know this panda is learning
martial arts which is atypical for wild
pandas but believe it or not pandas can
fight pandas have claws and they have
fangs long fangs that could rip through
tissue really easily so they have the
physical structure to be very very
aggressive and violent if they want to I
love this movie but I have to give it a
one out of ten
years they're awesome they are not only
the largest of all eight bear species
they're also the largest carnivore on
the planet and they are very aggressive
so to have a very violent interaction
between two alpha male polar bears is
realistic they're not going to have like
an audience of other polar bears maybe
if there's like a big common food source
they would congregate together other
than that they're not really cooperating
like that
the other thing that we wouldn't really
see in a polar bear polar bear fight is
the running and slamming together
usually when they're fighting they
approach each other slowly they'll do
all the bluff charges to each other and
then they'll get up on their hind legs
and start fighting but they won't kind
of knock each other back and then run at
each other together again
they don't eat people they don't eat
each other but they're more likely to be
extremely aggressive polar bears are
what we call obligate carnivores right
so that means they just want to hunt and
kill and eat and because of that it
impacts our behaviors they often say
like if it's white good night it means
that if you are in an attack with a
polar bear it's not looking good as well
done as the art was I would give it like
a two out of 10.
[Music]
oh
what the it goes without saying
that this is like extremely exaggerated
the bear was like slapping back and that
was actually kind of realistic in fact
like it doesn't take a lot of energy for
them to like slap you across the face
but punching a bear in the face is just
a really great way to irritate them and
to get them to really hurt you
I'm running to Fury tractor we can't
ride a bear it's kind of worth
explaining that over the years
Bears have been used in like circuses
and entertainment capacity don't train
wild animals there's a lot of Ethics
around this probably bear riding has
been a thing but these days you're not
really going to find it anywhere I would
give it again like a three out of ten
oh my God
oh
ah that's something that every camper is
worried about if they're camping in a
place where Bears could be Bears will
smell something good in your tent and
will come looking for it so it looks
like she just uncapped her bear spray
really glad to see that bear spray is
something that I have on me at all times
whenever I'm in the wilderness it can
save your life
yeah
this is where this woman went wrong bear
spray is completely 100 ineffective when
you're in close proximity with the bear
it's just going to aggravate it and make
it attack you you use it when there's a
bear in the distance bear spray is
pepper spray but it's not the same kind
of pepper spray that we use to keep
ourselves safe it is extremely powerful
and it shoots at a long distance so if
you sprayed bear spray in your tent you
would not be able to breathe you
wouldn't be able to see like you would
be incapacitated you have to do it in
the open and then you have to get
yourself out of there so what they
should have done is at the beginning of
the clip unzip the tent spray the bear
spray zip it back up and wait a few
minutes and see what happens
that one was intense it would have to
have so many interactions with humans
that it learns a behavior to become a
killer like a deliberate predator of
humans also the bear spray situation
could have saved them way before the
attack actually happened I wish they had
just deployed the bear spray the right
way I wanted to give it like a nine out
of ten because I was like camping black
bear fear like that all makes sense but
then in terms of how aggressive and how
like murderous that bear was I want to
give it like a four out of 10.
foreign
oh my God what is that kind of has like
the humps and lumps of a bearish we can
see like it has this extended kind of
snap almost like a horse head and then
like a more flat head black bear will
either have like the extended snap but
then like a proper hump her head or a
brown bear a grizzly bear has more of
like the flattened face and like a much
rounder head it's all over the place
one of the things that I'm also noticing
is that looks like there's places where
it's like missing fur and just has raw
skin and believe it or not this is
actually kind of accurate because there
are times when bears can be very
susceptible to mange the same mange that
dogs can get so it's possible that like
a mangy bear
influenced this this animal here okay
I'm gonna give it a one out of ten like
that wasn't even a real animal my
favorite Bear show is a show that I've
actually been in and I don't think it's
fair to really toot my own horn right
here so I will say that my second
favorite Bear show was Yogi Bear and it
was mostly about this bear named Yogi
who lived in a national park and would
steal people's picnic baskets but it's
kind of realistic right like bears are
in a lot of America's national parks and
they love our food that's something that
humans and Bears have in common thanks
for watching if you liked this video why
not click on the video above
foreign